Comcast Johnson Danny Elfman man this is
like seeing Robert DeNiro in Rocky and
Bullwinkle it required three editors to
do this
total gap right moment here is this girl
doesn't look nearly sick enough to stay
home from meeting prized interview
Christian Grey pawning it off on the
movies protagonist amazing parking can
be and in downtown Seattle during peak
business hours I realize you want to
visually emphasize her oh and how out of
her element she is but she literally
just walked away from a car without
feeding the meter so that's getting
towed Wow what's that I've never heard
an elevator make noise before haha
Johnson inkblot panda art diminishes the
importance of both pandas and the
greater inkblot painting movement as a
whole whirlwind of super hot
receptionist keeps her from telling the
truth about her identity so that the
reveal will occur extra awkwardly during
her meeting with mr. gray
receptionist assistant supermodel makes
this girl open the huge heavy office
door by herself
and naturally it gives her an
opportunity to be awkward and clumsy in
front of the super squab business guy
Anastasia Steele so his name is grey and
her name is steel and I'm supposed to
take any of this seriously meet his
previous lovers tracee chrome and Vickie
tungsten five pencils of gray what do I
owe my success seriously yeah the
question is lame but Christian Grey's
being such a dick tart about it to the
replacement interviewer reading a
college students question Jesus like I
may have a big dick but he also is a big
dick dick maybe you're just lucky okay
movie hold the fucking phone you can't
spend all movie up to now trying to
convince me that she's nervous shy
reluctant and awkward and then ever turn
into Rihanna and toss this sassy
confident bar back at him after the
first goddamn question he answers are
you gay Anastasia sees the question on
the paper and actually goes through with
asking this mr. grey your next meeting
is in the conference forecast it's
literally been four minutes since he
said as I said that I only have ten
minutes I would like to know more about
you Christian has the same weird
attraction to Anastasia that Edward does
to Bella in Twilight wait this story
came out of Twilight fan fiction holy Sh
that's like recycling all the on-screen
action of two girls in one cup tell me
was it Charlotte brontë Jane Austen or
Thomas Hardy who first made you fall in
love of literature it can only be one of
these three authors you tell that
dickhead Nathaniel Hawthorne he will
never get a fifty Shades of Grey
reference as long as he keeps shoving
that scarlet winter nonsense in our
faces and this
Dasia Christian well I'm glad they could
Brio firm their names to each other
whenever I get writer's block I go back
and study James Cameron's Titanic always
breaks me out of it
getting what Kate is clearly in the
Images tab of a discount Google and
types Christian Grey News into the
search field and the results
miraculously give her news despite this
fact also it goes straight to some
random article rather than giving her
search results also this guy could not
be more displeased to be fake meeting
Christian Grey for this made-up movie
photo I guess Kate went to the news for
two seconds and then hit the back button
so that Anastasia could dramatically
look at Christian smoldering not Google
photos Apple one of their MacBook Air
product placement to feel perfectly
natural except for the obviously generic
search engine being used which almost
acts as a subconscious product lace Minh
for Google actually so in your face
Apple movie goes full unsubtle with the
sexual metaphors but suggests Christian
Grey's penis has major issues with width
and totally in love with her but have no
chance face a bunch of nonsense
first off breaking your foot playing
golf second off her new husband breaks
his foot and she can't go to her own
daughter's graduation for it I'd
understand if this mom was an unloving a
strange kind of mother but this is weak
sauce hey it's not actress I always
think it's Meryl Streep's daughter but
it's actually rosemary Harris's daughter
so oh man they drank that actress I
think his Meryl Streep's daughter into
this didn't they so she works at a
hardware store where Christian can just
so happen to buy items not intended for
bondage I wonder how this scene would
have played out if Anastasia worked at
the gap be free he said to the person
obviously working a shift at this retail
establishment maybe coveralls so you
protect your clothes could just take all
my clothes off what a whore
that must have been a really amazing
moment for you that this movie decided
not to show for some reason I'm used to
getting my own way and that's campaign
boring it sounds like the script gets
it's only two they should have called
this girl anesthesia steel I don't do
the girlfriend thing
what is this watch premium rush nearly
causes an accident and provides fifty
shades of gray with a hundred minutes
more material that would have had
otherwise you're on my list Joseph
gordon-levitt professor narrates exactly
how all the men in the audience are
feeling right now no one will be seated
during the anesthesia has to be seen
this is if you've been drinking
Christian chastises anesthesia for
drinking despite the fact that she
doesn't know that rule yet and they're
not in a relationship anyway and why
should he even give a half a movie that
promised me kinky sex has gone over 23
minutes without offering up any kinky
sex dude who just made a big deal asking
her to tell him where she was suddenly
realizes he's best friends with the
screenwriter and can easily find out
where she is by just asking that dude I
don't know either but I'm guessing after
it's too late cuz she already loves a
dog
aka now Jose straight-up has no idea
what no means no you did not hear her
though obviously you're right that she
did say no but still overly aggressive
rescue male is overly aggressive also
Jose is a one-note I'm in love with
Anastasia and that's my whole reason for
existence character
I'm surprised Ana didn't say no way Jose
that old cliche would have been perfect
for this movie this asshole can any girl
he wants but somehow is so fixated on
this one socially awkward puking college
girl that he's willing to basically be
her butler nanny also normal girl
inexplicably attracted to creepy guy who
was way over-the-top about stalking and
trying to protect her I realized this
movies authors started out as a Twilight
fan fiction author but damn the only way
this could be more Twilight as if he was
literally also a vampire she's just
gonna swallow those pills and that
liquid as though they're 100% what they
appear to be even if they are that's
still stupidest Taylor Lautner came this
close to winning this role on the
strength of his audition for this scene
alone if you were mine you wouldn't be
able to sit down for a week from
spanking or okay or just basic orders
following I am so confused by this guy's
boner
oh man they dragged toast into this
didn't they well even the bellow lip
bite is lifted from Twilight this is
when we have one single fucking thing to
offer me that is original
besides the kinky sex which incidentally
still hasn't shown up at the 30 fucking
minute mark Taylor has good taste
you mean the stealer that's incorrect
Christian refers to Anastasia as
paperwork and we must be going
I think Christians brother finished the
sexy started with Kate in the bedroom
why does he have to leave just Christian
some sort of sexual EMP later Christian
says they have work to do but come on
what a bunch of nonsense
[Music]
[Applause]
this helicopter Ryan from Portland to
Seattle is brought to you by love me
like you do by ellie goulding
also remember the movie singles that was
a pretty good Pacific Northwest movie
Sleepless in Seattle was decent ever
since we've had stuff like Mad Love and
Twilight and this bullshit
come on Seattle inspire better dammit
Anastasia hurriedly signs the shady NDA
without inspecting it like it's a itunes
Terms of Service Agreement are you
almost 37 minutes and still no kinky sex
movie is a liar and a tease and now if
kinky sex happens I'm going to be too
angry about the lack of kinky sex to be
excited about it
I'm cleaner Thank You Xbox and stuff
honey wine but the movie is telling us
she really is this naive which is total
bullshit at her age and the fact that
she's an English Lit major who's
probably run across at all themes in her
life saw franchise based sex room also
Christian decides the best way to
prepare women for his sex dungeon is to
simply spring it on them without the
slightest bit of preparation also she
still doesn't leave after this because
inside every college girl apparently is
the desire to be dominated and by a man
with more money than you it's called a
flogger I am awesome at Frogger
wait it's called a flogger because at
this very moment I bet all you're
concerned about is what the proper name
of everything is you're a sadist I'm a
dominant
skip you want me to move in that's full
time just Friday through to Sunday
BDSM isn't open during business hours
you're still a virgin you're biting your
lip
Christian Grey would be excellent at
cinema sinning the Twilight movies a
Jewish man who has only turned on by
doing dominant-submissive in the bedroom
is able to do it the Manila way in a
pinch simply because he's making an
investment in BDSM futures kinky sex
movie awaits nearly 43 minutes to
commence with the kinky sex just in case
you don't want to waste your time on the
first 43 minutes like I did two full
minutes of disrobing
so it's at this point I wonder did
Melanie Griffith and Don Johnson Pat
Johnson watch this movie with their
daughters simulating sex acts through
hell that's gotta be the weirdest
premiere ever right not that Melanie
Griffith was ever shot either but damn
that's her daughter up there of course
she's a movie virgin so this is the best
sex ever had by a virgin in the history
of first times it's not painful and she
has 15 G spots don't you hate it when a
guy takes your virginity and then
decides to play the piano while you're
fast asleep let's get you cleaned up
I'm gonna do it with my tongue hope
that's not too weird movie decides that
an audience of mostly women can't handle
seeing some dudes junk movie is rated R
right why does it exciting make a movie
worse for anyone who might run across it
even if kids managed to sneak into this
movie does seeing a penis scar then more
than the boobs in the butts not to
mention the overall poor quality of this
movie and this is the exact moment Don
Johnson called the spy to order a new
television set disrespect why would she
trust you now that you've had sex twice
you're sure to be ready for this this is
done longer than we think it is mom
shows up out of nowhere without a phone
call because I'm almost certain they
just wanted to introduce the mom
character and breakup the only fun you
might be having with this movie also
they drag Marcia Gay Harden into this
didn't they she won an Oscar you know I
mean winning an Oscar should
automatically disqualify you for being
in a movie like this okay take it I was
just showing your mother huh seriously
how bad is that assistant Taylor at his
job that he couldn't have just told
Christians mom that he was out and
unavailable she basically came into
cotton now she's being walked out after
a minute of screen time you agreed to do
this you're gonna win your own room why
cuz I'll be your sex slave I don't want
to do this here let's talk to us tears
because downstairs this conversation
becomes different somehow
movies woman symbolizes all the men
watching this movie well the man
symbolizes the women allele if you have
any questions I told you my computer's
down needless minor plot complication is
needless but mainly so Christian can
mysteriously hire a guy to come by and
set up a new computer to show how much
he BDSM I mean love sir you look
different I feel different ah homegirls
can tell when other girls have found
their first sex cliche I guess we'll
never get rid of these characters in
romantic movies the friend who's mainly
there to encourage the protagonist to
get laid character who the hell is Kate
she's entirely defined by how much she
wants her friend to have sex and smile
at her when she finally does I still
haven't figured out that you're the most
naive person in the world so the kind of
research you need to do on this computer
should be totally implied lutely
characters will now send a series of
texts and ions to each other on screen
because clearly the actors revolted when
asked to repeat too many words from this
script the following are the terms of a
binding contract between the dominant
and the submissive contract narration
will be consensual confidential
previously on 50 shades of grey Jesus
she's just now asking this question dan
this fake Google has three different tab
link bars to choose from this is the
most desperate Google competitor ever
somehow Christian is able to get inside
Anastasia's room despite the fact that
he's a vampire and he's never been
invited in Christian takes a page for
nine and a half weeks which still might
be more boring than this movie this guy
manages to tear the wrapper off a condom
put it on and be inside her in like two
seconds
breaking all known world records for
condom use is really nice it was well I
guess I'll have to take your word for
pressuring a girl into signing an NDA
bondage sex contract one day a whole
movie is going to just be texting and
messaging two characters will have sex
on screen and be texting their moans to
each other it'll be like the silent era
all over again
only more technology and nudity
impressive it is this is the darkest
business meeting I've ever been in and
there isn't even any donuts or coffee
around how does Christian negotiate
deals this way if they can't see me
maybe they won't know how much I'm
screwing them find anal fisting I'm all
ears
strike it out this is probably how the
whole movie should have been with
everyone realizing how stupid the story
is and not taking it so seriously really
it just served to show what could have
been and therefore is a sin why don't
bucks yes that's a funny question but
you have that fake Google right how did
you not just fake Google what the plugs
are and figure it out on your own I
would help you out of that little dress
of yours they'll be pleased to discover
that you're naked underneath Christian
describes what the literal pleasure of
taking someone's clothes off is this
isn't sexy talk it's just facts her
friend Kate is the valedictorian of this
school how badly did everyone else fuck
up if Kate is the valedictorian by the
way he didn't Anastasia say she had a
4.0 GPA how does she have that GPA and
not at least be Co valedictorian okay
there are so many words in that sentence
that don't make sense to me I think it
was during the filming of this scene
that these two actors realize how much
damage they've done to their careers by
appearing in this movie are you doing a
few things at the office the require my
attention but so you can sit here alone
and dramatically reflect on whether you
want to be in this kind of relationship
or not it's as good a reason as any
other to get me out of here for now
sorry I missed your graduation Bob broke
his finger reading a book of all things
we really think he asked that samuel
l.jackson and unbreakable disease I'm
gonna take you to mine Clara the contact
they've been talking about paperwork for
an hour and the movie is 30 minutes away
from being finished at what point is the
dominant you say well I don't even need
to spank her or love her or this she's
not
- it kind of search Craigslist that's
right his hand went down into her crotch
area what are you gonna do about it
American Midwest movie goes full Passion
of the Christ which my penis was not
prepared for where are we going wait a
minute they just had sex he put her in a
bed she woke up and it's nighttime and
it's time to go to his mom's house what
just happened remember my mother
mentioned dinner seems like it was
months ago but I assure you all this
that happened from the time she
mentioned it to now is only been a week
after all we do live in Seattle and we'd
like to remind the audience of that
Oh understand she hasn't even signed the
goddamn contract yet asshole what do you
want I want you so that about covers the
extent of this discussion doesn't she
just sign the contract you wouldn't skip
woman they gave birth to me was a crack
addict a prostitute bottled up character
finally opens up but only when the other
person is asleep cliche Jesus her mom
didn't even pick her up at the airport
and is the worst loving mom ever Dan
Christian's gotten her a new car and a
new computer but she's still using this
phone from the dark ages more exciting
texting I came to see you and no one in
this movie is gonna think that's creepy
sure you're rich but this is like the
fourth time you've shown up unannounced
wherever Anastasia was stalking is a
crime an even if you have had sex with
the person you're stalking broke rule
seven Clause five let it go this would
be a really good time to remind you and
the audience that you haven't signed the
contract yet which is something you guys
love to argue about a lot so nobody's
broken any rules here and nobody has the
power to let it go so let's not talk
about the contract right now
but talking about not signing the
contract is the only thing that keeps
you together well what did she advise
you to do well I'm here seeing Christian
with his dominant would have actually
been really interesting but this movie
avoids interesting like it's the clap
movie wastes even more time with a sexy
flying scene I think this movie could
have been finished in 30 seconds
Anastasia Christian do you want me given
whip you know yet so besides his wealth
and the crazy activities and gifts he
buys for with said wealth is there
anything she sees in him I certainly
know chemistry between them why does she
even want to be this dude's girlfriend
so is this enough to hurt you for my
pleasure now who park Christians car
here remember when they got to the
airfield well I sure do because I was
paying attention very closely why don't
you stop trying to make me believe for
one second this car was ever parked
right next to the hangar you dumb jokes
what are you afraid of it's amazing how
many times someone gets a phone call or
has to go do something when they have
this conversation it's almost like the
movie itself knows house
but it is and how inevitable the outcome
is that it keeps buying time to be long
enough for a movie director and the prop
master had a dispute over what
constitutes too much rope and no kinky
sex expert but does a delicate peacock
feather have any business in the paint
chamber and it's probably fine I just
want an excuse to say peacock because it
doesn't happen very often and it has the
word cock in it hey remember that movie
secretary that came out a while back I
think I'm gonna go watch that movie
instead
let's stop and recap all the beats in
this movie that feel like Twilight Earl
in the Pacific Northwest go somewhere
new and meets mysterious rich man for
weird encounter then he stalks her but
she thinks that's cool but he has a dark
secret world she can sense but not fully
gained access to he roughs up a guy
coming on too strong they walk in the
woods she has a remarried mother far
away to have stupid phone chats with
from time to time about life and love
said distant mom says come see me to
escape your love life for a bit and she
goes and to nighttime him playing the
piano scenes damn I know you love
Twilight but did you have to copy all of
it why won't you let me in we should be
talking is there really anything to talk
about at this point this is exactly what
the screenwriters should have said about
an hour ago not only about the contract
in the movie but the contract to write
this script why do you want to punish me
why do you want to hurt me you're just
now asking these questions why do you
need because it's where I am I don't
know what's so hard about saying when I
hurt people I achieve orgasms I also
don't see how Anastasia doesn't know
this also millions around the world
getting off to this story of abuse
blatant emotional and physical abuse
most of it in a cultish sexual setting
there's like only one or two shades of
grey separating this guy from Buffalo
Bill it goes this guy Billy Zane and
Titanic Marky Mark from fear then
Buffalo Bill Fifty Shades of fun punish
me I want you to show me the worst it's
the only way I can understand but you
crossed out the anal fisting I kind of
regret asking for the worst face you
know what I mean
goddamn yes how much research did you do
on this how did you have a 4.0 GPA and
not have the least bit of curiosity when
it comes to your boyfriend's fetish
which is readily available to know in an
intimate way on the internet how can you
be this freaking stupid to eat dick
okay so she's figured it out she knows
what a monster he is so why are there at
least two more movies coming well damn
that argument nearly killed my orgasm
nearly she stayed there in his apartment
you'll never do that to me again
but that stuff with the peacock feather
I think it's still gonna be okay with
that before or after the violence bank
beating I see it started raining just in
time for the mood to be set perfectly I
know it's Seattle but this is some damn
convenient rain right here Christian I'm
glad they could get that straight at the
end of the movie
so we just contract
let's duel and she'll address him
[Music]
I don't do the girlfriend thing I don't
do romance I don't make love I told you
I don't sleep with anymore
it's a way that's not really my thing I
don't want to do this here never slept
next to anyone I told you I don't sleep
with any you're not fighting fair I
never have that's not something I know
you said you didn't do I don't because
it's the way I am
[Music]
what I thought we were in the trust tree
with in the nest are we not we are okay
please continue
actually Jeremy you're totally right
about the cult thing cults follow an
eight step process to indoctrinate new
recruits in Christian gray throughout
the movie follows the exact same steps
it's all about psychological
manipulation and if you want to check
out the real dark side of Fifty Shades
click right here I have a film theory
all about it have a look if you dare
Fifty Shades of effed-up indeed
[Music]
look at that subtle off-white coloring a
tasteful thickness of it oh my god it
even has a watermark by mr. gray shops
are turning your idea with a fitted
bedroom upside down and creating rooms
to living and to sleep in individual
design or beautiful installed
[Music]
but it has been murdered by crystal-meth
Drake
[Music]
dad a lot